the iconic character I'm about to create
as the [ __ ] in this interview I am
better boss Colin these are my iconic
characters a good wife
I think everyone kind of expected
something that was titled The Good Wife
to be this kind of schlocky silly soapy
kind of thing and then it turned into
like seven seasons of like the best
network television that we've seen I
loved doing that show I've been doing a
lot of TV it was maybe one of my first
recurring roles one of my first roles
that became kind of recurring signed it
up doing six episodes of The Good Wife I
played like this [ __ ] attorney
Nathan Landry who was keeping julianna
margulies Alicia Florrick's husband
Peter Florrick in jail he was trying to
get out on bail this was like mid first
season it was his Florrick I have one
more question did you meet with a
divorce attorney on February 23rd they
didn't have sets yet so we shot in a
real Queens County Courthouse so they
were night shoots because it was a
functioning courthouse in Queens
during the day so the only time we could
shoot the the courthouse scenes in the
first season was overnight they actually
had consultants courtroom consultants
lawyers and stuff on set and they would
tell you you wouldn't really stand in
this moment it wouldn't be appropriate
you wouldn't approach the witness like
that and etc so that we were in really
good hands that that shows amazing some
of my favorite shows I continued
watching it long after I was an
afterthought the Mentalist
there I was like the kind of like sad
love interest that was the first time I
got to be like let's bring somebody in
so that people start freaking out that
these two might not end up together and
then I made one of my best friends Robin
Tunney she was kind of like the film
indie queen through the 90s and just so
beautiful in such a good actress and and
then we became such good friends
I loved doing that scene with her she's
in a red dress and and and and we're
we're having dinner and I'm asking her
it seems like on our second date to move
to Washington DC with me rezoning I
don't want you to go I really don't
okay with me
I'm asking what if we went to DC you and
me together
moves fast I move fast we had our own
like little theme music
just want to say and I know moving to DC
is a big thing and it might raise issues
you don't feel totally comfortable
talking to me about it was amazing Game
of Thrones never heard of it
there's a little little show called Game
of Thrones let me explain it to you for
those of you that don't know anyway
let's just end that joke there
the yeah go burn Oberon [ __ ]
Martell man the red Viper what do you
want change my life they have the whole
season all the episodes are written and
you know scheduled based on location for
it to shoot like a 10-hour movie at
least when it was 10 episodes in the
fourth season if so it feels like doing
a big movie and and basically you can
shoot something in Episode seven and
then go back to episode two and then you
know and that happened to mean for me
my my big acting and dialogue scene with
one of the best actors in the world on
my very first day of shooting she always
gets what she wants
and what about what I want justice for
my sister and her children do i have to
describe what that felt like I was
terrified and and and and it was amazing
it was just very surreal because I was
also stepping on to the set of a show
that I was obsessed with and I was
seeing you know and and and we had a
rehearsal you know the day before and
Peter Dinklage I've seen him on stage
he's an incredibly generous actor so he
just was just like sitting down and
doing a scene with a pro over and over
and over and over again when you see a
helicopter spin jumps about six feet in
the air
That's not me
that would be Lang who is a wushu expert
and master and has gone on to do the
Jedi fights in the Star Wars movies and
but I did learn the fight I did training
in in Los Angeles for a couple of weeks
before going and shooting and then
throughout the whole shoot before
getting to the fight there were fight
for our souls and fight training and
stuff like that it was very very
specifically choreographed and if you
see my face it is me
[Applause]
[Music]
earlier mark time do you want to know
how they did it
he had tubing through his arms that
would come out from his thumbs so he's
he's seven feet 420 pounds when we were
shooting he might be big he might you
know I think he might he could be
heavier now because when we shot he was
the third strongest man in the world and
now he's the first strongest man in the
world so he you know puts his thumbs
over my eyes and then they start pumping
the fake blood
I got teeth made just so that if you got
a flash of what my mouth looked like
after my teeth got knocked out like
they're so meticulous it's unbelievable
then there was a cast of my of my head
from shoulder you know to top or just a
regular cast and also one with like the
you know frozen expression of absolute
anguish
it was really funny because there were
just things lost in cross communication
in terms of the UK and and and and North
America in terms of whether or not I had
been cast in the part and as far as HBO
was concerned it was official as far as
my agents were concerned it wasn't and
so I was getting goop poured over my
head and they were casting my like like
building my head to be crushed and I was
just like did I get the part why does
this mean I'm doing it you know it's
kind of funny not of course that was my
first series regular role of which I had
been like you know clamoring for for so
many years I can't tell you how the
whole thing in Colombia even if there
were scenes that uh that take place in
Texas or Miami or something like that we
found with locations all around Colombia
or in Panama but all three seasons that
I shot we shot in Colombia we we all got
started on it together you know we were
all part of the the freshmen chapter of
season one in Colombia and that meant so
many things in terms of creating and
inventing the subtle or not so subtle
details about the character and this is
my partner Javier Pena who figured the
best way to get inside narco information
was to hang out with the same women they
did pretty close I met him before I met
even my bosses he was a great guy he's
really relaxed easygoing guy um he's not
expecting anything from you he's not
putting any kind of pressure on you he
doesn't want to insist on telling you
like I'm giving you insights he's just
like hey what's up you know I like Coors
Light what do you like and and it was
funny too because I I was apprehensive
about the training and I found it
intimidating and I just was really
nervous about the whole thing and Boyd
was like we're gonna go
we're going to Quantico we're gonna do
this and I was like do we have to tell
your opinion you know he was like when
we were at Quantico he's like just
bringing up some intense memories I was
like what you mean he's like hmm just
you know it's intense it's like okay I'm
with you men you know I feel like there
is a loner aspect to him that I could I
could really connect to because it takes
place in the 80s and all that 80's
clothes just looks like I look like I
was playing dress-up I look like a kid I
look like a child like I just got lost
in it and I looked like a dork and so I
came up with this idea I was like you
know let's just say Javier Pena is like
Don Draper in that like the 70s is his
like that was where he really found
himself and he can't really and so he's
stuck there he's not throwing those
pants out he's not changing his hair
he's not changing his shoes it's his
time and he's gonna look like that until
the day he dies that was my
justification Kingsman V Golden Circle
to be in in moves of this size and to in
Matthew Vaughn he is such a Natur and
and and in specific filmmaker because
he's so specific and uncompromising
about his aesthetic and what he wants it
to how he wants it and everything he's
also a really fun guy to be around and
and that was about you know him teaching
me that I could actually do these things
and play this kind of a character and do
that kind of action and pull it off it
was not anything that I could imagine
even after having done Game of Thrones
there was so much character and
emotional history with with a character
like Oberon and with whisky it was just
like flash you know what I mean and to
sit at a table with Colin Firth and Jeff
Bridges and Halle Berry and Julianne
Moore's over there and Channing Tatum's
over here
you know what I mean it just I just like
had to stop myself from asking for
autographs there is this incredible
lassu whip and gun-slinging expert he's
the one who trained me and did the
jumping through the so that he when you
see the jumping through the the lasso
loop
that is new Rollins is his name and he
is actually doing that he is doing all
of that
he's boundless in his capacity to to
manipulate a whip a lasso and and guns
equalizer to remember my agents were
like they want to know if you'd be
willing to audition and I was like
willing to audition to be in a movie
with Denzel Washington directed by
Antoine Fuqua you know crack absolutely
not
offer only I auditioned to my ass off
for them it's like what do you want me
to do you know and tons of Washington is
my movie star you know what I mean and
not yours nobody else is mine I just
wanted to sit next to him which I got to
do and more obviously
[Music]
that's right
I had to tell them was like you know
this was referencing something specific
and they're like what and I was like
don't worry about it
she wasn't you to be a part of an
ensemble cast with a bunch of dudes that
are such good actors and to work with
frankly one of my best friends with whom
I did my first play in New York with 14
years ago and and and we were doing this
like really intricate car chase scene
and he's in the back of the pickup and
I'm in the driver's seat I hear his
voice behind my head and he's like here
we are in an action movie together in
Hawaii and I was like was so crazy you
know it's just so so funny I would have
never have been able to like compose
that for my future it's so weird catfish
that's why playing he's I I I'm the
pilot and the driver I feel like I
always get behind the wheel or in the
cockpit and and somehow that told me the
most about my character fish I need a
pilot I got the baby now this can change
you in that baby's life forever where he
kind of sits back he's a little bit more
in the shadows he doesn't have a lot to
say and then when it's decision time you
know he steps up prospect they're very
visionary young directors those two Zeke
Earl and Chris Caldwell that was a
really really tough shoot and it was
worth it because of what they capture
visually yeah it was it was miserable I
can't I tell you this was not a
big-budget film and and and I mean we
were all just you know we couldn't
breathe a huge challenge that was worth
it to them to the visual experience of
the movie and and be in those spacesuits
man lay you from nowhere oh boy
the Queen's lair
I'm ready to like do something where
like I'm sitting you know my character
doesn't really get up from a chair or
have anything to wear just just just
just just listen